[Music]
Kourtney Kardashian appears to be doing
a-okay
following her recent breakup that's in
God's hands after news broke that she
and her boyfriend of two years Eunice
Benjamin had split the mom of three hit
the town with her sister Kim who shared
this clip on social media the two also
documented their visit to a local
department store Coco and Kiki despite a
recent feud with her sisters Kourt got
support from both Kim and khloé who took
to social media to dis Eunice after he
was photographed on the beach with
another woman Kim commented on a repost
of his Instagram story quotes nice pics
from your boys trip while Coco added
Alexa play heard it all before by
sunshine Andersson prior to the recent
sibling outing Kim and court didn't seem
to be in the best place no one was there
he shoot I'm planning it don't want you
in the shoot after the season premiere
of Keeping Up with the Kardashians show
the two in a fight over scheduling the
family's annual Christmas card photo
shoot I need Kourtney to not be so you
know I'm with the stick up her ass like
run fish because she doesn't she's the
least
exciting to look at their famous momager
Kris Jenner stop by the Late Late Show
with James Corden and weighed in on the
sister war unlike the negotiator yeah so
I'm trying to negotiate like everybody
calmed down
it's a Christmas card shoot we're show
us to be singing like you know jingle
bells or something
[Music]